[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today we did a
fabulously attended free live stream
on real estate
interest rates had not yet climbed to
where they are now
uh but the covid rush the Falcon
pandemic quarantine Rush had eased and
the real estate market was cooling off
because interest rates had ticked up and
people were freaking out acting like the
real estate market was going to crash
and that prices were going to go down
I'll just wait till prices go down and
we were addressing that we had this big
podcast
um you were of course here you were
still in your first few months with us
at that point and uh it was very
successful we had I think a couple
hundred thousand folks watch that view
or watch that live stream I called it a
podcast watch that live stream and in it
we went through the details of the real
estate situation
and explained very carefully how
dramatically the supply of housing is
below the demand
and that any time there is a demand for
anything that is higher than the supply
if you took economics in the seventh
grade they taught you that that means
the prices will go up
when demand exceeds Supply prices will
go up the more demand exceeds Supply the
more prices will go up
as long as that is the perception in the
market and its prices are going to go up
that's what's going to happen and so we
told you house prices are not going to
tank
as a matter of fact they're probably
going to go up in 2023 about seven
percent now at that time we had two
types of house prices floating around we
had the people that had priced their
house way high and unrealistically
hoping to catch a sucker because there
were a bunch of suckers out there buying
property for anything and everything way
above appraisal yes okay that is not an
actual price that's a sucker yes that's
not a price and so uh now but and then
there were people that had priced their
homes at or around appraisal we were not
talking about sucker prices we were
talking about appraisal prices are not
going to come down we said you can
expect to see people calling prices
going down but really what it is it's
the asking price that's going down
because people quit uh fishing for
suckers okay and they get more realistic
and you're going to expect to see
instead of eight minutes uh time on the
market you can expect 80 or 90 days time
on the market which has been typical for
the last 50 years in the real estate
market that you mow the grass you trim
the bushes you paint the kids weird
bedroom and you vacuum and you steam
clean and you clean out the garage and
you clean out the closets and you put
fresh light bulbs in you put your house
on the market at a good price based on
what your good competent real estate
agent tells you to put it on at and it
will sell in 80 to 90 days for the last
50 years
with rare exceptions keyword competent
yeah and then yeah keyword competent and
keyword that you priced it properly
that's right okay so we told you a year
ago that you're not going to see house
prices going to go down we think they're
going to go up around seven percent they
went up 27 the year before but that was
based on the fauci uh pandemic
quarantine so
um
you know the people came out of their
houses after that quarantine like a
Baptist after a casserole and buying
stuff and buying stuff left and right
and so it went crazy and it jammed up
Supply Demand on everything we called it
supply chain supply chain supply chain
and all it was was people are buying
like nuts man and so now now the Wall
Street Journal reporting today
home prices aren't falling anymore after
declining on a year-over-year basis for
five consecutive months which includes
the prices with the suckers I was
talking about the longest run of
declines in 11 years U.S House Prices
rose in July
the surprisingly quick recovery
which really wasn't enough I'm not
surprised suggests that the residential
real estate downturn is turning out to
be shorter and shallower than many
housing economists expected after
mortgage rates soared last year scarcity
is a big reason
yeah Supply shortage hello yeah High
interest rates have prompted homeowners
to stay put rather than buying new homes
and take on more expensive mortgages
resulting in an unusually low inventory
of homes for sale no honey there was
already a lower inventory than there was
to banned now it's even worse because
demand has even slowed because of
interest rates prices are generously
holding generally holding firm outside
of a few trouble spots the national
median existing home price Rose
1.9 percent in July
it's almost two percent in one month
if you annualize that that's 24.
I don't think we're going to see that
yeah but um even in a market where
demand has been hammered by higher rates
the supply just isn't there says the
chief Economist at KPMG
short of a flood in Supply
it's hard to see these prices coming
down now how would you get a flood in
Supply well you'd have to see a building
boom and we are seeing quite the
opposite the number of spec homes being
built homes that don't already have a
buyer almost zero wow completely dried
up Builders quit doing them
and so there's not there's the opposite
of a flood of Supply there's a flood of
shortages coming so you're going to
continue to see real estate prices climb
we told you that